This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On a March afternoon in 1996, a Toronto Raptors, a brand new team in the NBA at the time, were playing the Chicago Bulls. The Bulls were the best team in the league, and the Raptors were pretty terrible. 36,000 fans showed up that day, and the Raptors actually beat the Bulls. But it was a mostly meaningless game at the end of the season. This is Reporter Whitney Jones. And what's so interesting to me about this game isn't who won or how the teams played.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1996年3月的一个下午，当时NBA的全新球队多伦多猛龙队正在对阵芝加哥公牛队。公牛队是联盟中最强的球队，而猛龙队则相当糟糕。那天有3.6万名球迷到场，猛龙队居然击败了公牛队。但这只是一场在赛季末期基本上没什么意义的比赛。这是记者惠特尼·琼斯。这场比赛让我觉得最有趣的地方，不是谁赢了，也不是两队的表现。
But the way they looked, there's the Bulls who are just classic NBA. They've had the same logos since 1966. They're wearing their red-awaited jerseys that look basically like every Chicago Bulls jersey ever. It's red with the word bulls written across the front and black and white lettering. It's simple, classic. But then, there's the Toronto Raptors. The team is wearing their white home uniforms, which have jagged silver and black pinstripes as if they were cut
而是他们的外观。公牛队完全是经典的NBA风格。自1966年以来，他们一直使用相同的标志。他们穿着红色的客场（注：此处原文awaited实为away之误）球衣，基本上看起来和芝加哥公牛队历史上的每一件球衣都一样。红色底色，胸前印着“Bulls”字样，搭配黑白字标。简单、经典。但接着是多伦多猛龙队。全队穿着白色主场球衣，上面有锯齿状的银色和黑色细条纹，就好像被
by slashing Raptor claws, and then across the whole front, there's a giant red basketball playing dinosaur, who himself is wearing sneakers and a uniform, a totally different uniform, and he's dribbling a basketball. And that was just their home uniform. The road jerseys that year were even more fun. They were bright purple. All of this, including the Raptor's name, had been inspired by the velociraptors in the wildly successful movie Jurassic Park. But these jerseys got compared to a different, much friendlier 90s dinosaur. That's now known as the Barney design because they're road uniform as purple. This is Paul Lucas, uniform obsessive and writer of a column at ESPN called UniWatch. It just, it looks so cartoonish and so ridiculous.
猛龙凶猛的爪子划破了一样；而在整个胸前，则有一只巨大的红色打篮球的恐龙，它自己穿着运动鞋和一套完全不同的队服，正在运着篮球。而这还只是他们的主场队服。那一年的客场球衣更有趣。它们是亮紫色的。所有这一切，包括猛龙队的名字，灵感都来自轰动全球的电影《侏罗纪公园》中的迅猛龙。但这些球衣却被拿来与90年代另一只友好得多的恐龙作比较。现在它被称为“巴尼”设计，因为它们的客场球衣是紫色的。这是保罗·卢卡斯，球衣狂热爱好者，也是ESPN专栏《UniWatch》的撰稿人。它看起来太卡通、太荒谬了。
You look at it and it's like really? That's a professional, professional top level team. The Raptors jersey may have been particularly garish, but it wasn't the only jersey of its kind. The 90s were this insane decade of NBA uniform design that produced some of the wildest jerseys that have ever graced a basketball court. Loud, wacky designs, the likes of which had never been seen before, and haven't been seen since. Like the Atlanta Hawks read in black jersey with a fierce-looking hawk swooping in across
你看着它，会想：真的吗？这是一支职业的、最高水平的球队。猛龙队的球衣可能格外的花哨，但它并不是同类球衣中的唯一一件。90年代是NBA球衣设计疯狂的一个十年，诞生了篮球场上见过的最狂野的一些球衣。张扬、古怪的设计，在此之前从未见过，此后也未曾再现。比如亚特兰大老鹰队的红黑球衣，上面有一只凶猛的老鹰扑向
the entire front of it, holding a basketball in its little talons. Or the Milwaukee Bucks Green uniform with a giant picture of a purple stag. Paul Lucas called this one great. I mean, great in the sense that it was so awful, it was great. They had this purple, garish, purple and green color pattern,
整个胸前，小爪子里抓着一个篮球。或者密尔沃基雄鹿队的绿色球衣，上面印着一只巨大的紫色雄鹿图片。保罗·卢卡斯称赞这件球衣“棒极了”。我的意思是，它是指丑到极点，所以棒极了。它们有这种紫色、花哨的紫色和绿色配色方案，
and it's just ridiculous. But it definitely, all these designs, definitely, they pushed and extended the idea of what a basketball uniform could be or should be. And many of these designs can be traced back to one man. I'm Tom O'Grady. I joined the NBA in 1990 as League's first creative director. Tom grew up in Chicago, sketching and resketching the logos of his hometown Chicago Black Hawks,
简直荒谬至极。但毫无疑问，所有这些设计绝对都推动和拓展了人们对篮球球衣可以是什么或应该是什么的认知。而其中许多设计都可以追溯到一个人。我是汤姆·奥格雷迪。我在1990年加入NBA，担任联盟的第一任创意总监。汤姆在芝加哥长大，一直在素描和重新描绘他家乡芝加哥黑鹰队的标志，
another classic pro hockey teams. Tom's love for sports and eye-catching art made this new NBA gig a dream job. My first day at the NBA was just filled with excitement. I'd always been a big sports fan and I loved design and my studied graphic design here at Columbia College back in Chicago. And so when I walked in the door in June of 1990, I kind of had to pinch myself because I really didn't believe what was happening.
另一支经典的职业冰球队。汤姆对体育的热爱以及对引人注目的艺术的敏锐眼光，使这份新的NBA工作成为了梦想中的工作。我进入NBA的第一天充满了兴奋。我一直是个超级体育迷，我热爱设计，曾在芝加哥的哥伦比亚学院学习平面设计。所以当我在1990年6月走进那扇门时，我甚至得掐自己一下，因为我真的不敢相信这一切正在发生。
Before Tom O'Grady joined the league, most NBA jerseys look something like that classic bull's jersey. They had simple two or three color schemes with the team names across the league. Most NBA jerseys look something like that classic bull's jersey. They had simple two or three color schemes with the team names across the front. There might have been a stripe here or there, maybe a cool font, but that was about it. And they weren't designed by designers. The process of designing team uniforms is mostly left up to team equipment managers, because they were responsible for getting the players outfitted to play the games. Mostly this consisted of the equipment managers flipping through a catalog,
在汤姆·奥格雷迪加入联盟之前，大多数NBA球衣看起来都和那件经典的公牛队球衣差不多。它们采用简单的两到三种配色方案，胸前印着各队的队名。联盟中大多数NBA球衣看起来都有些像那件经典的公牛队球衣。它们的配色方案很简单，只有两三种颜色，胸前印着球队名称。可能这里或那里有一条条纹，也许有一个酷炫的字体，但基本上就是这样。而且它们不是由设计师设计的。设计球队队服的过程主要交给球队的装备经理，因为他们负责为球员配备比赛装备。这通常包括装备经理翻阅目录，
choosing a design they liked with the right colors. It was not a sophisticated business, let's say that. They were happy just to get uniforms on the players' backs. But that was all about to change because in 1988, Charlotte Hornets introduced a radical new idea, Because in 1988, the Charlotte Hornets introduced a radical new idea, the color teal. In this archival news footage from 1988, Hornets player Kelly Trapuka stands on stage in front of flashing cameras. Then he rips off his teal-terra-way warm-ups to reveal the Hornets' new uniforms. Teal was not a traditional NBA jersey color. It's not NBA red, it's not NBA blue, it's not Celtic screen, it's not Lakers yellow. Tom O'Grady had nothing to do with the T.O. Hornets uniform, but he took it as a sign
选择一款自己喜欢的、颜色合适的图案。可以说这不是一门成熟的生意。他们只要能让球员穿上球衣就很开心了。但这一切即将改变，因为在1988年，夏洛特黄蜂队引入了一个激进的新理念，因为在1988年，夏洛特黄蜂队引入了一个激进的新理念——蒂芙尼蓝（青绿色）。在这段1988年的资料新闻片段中，黄蜂队球员凯利·特拉普卡站在闪烁的相机前。然后他撕下了他那青绿色的撕开式热身服，露出了黄蜂队的新球衣。蒂芙尼蓝并不是传统的NBA球衣颜色。它不是NBA红，不是NBA蓝色，不是凯尔特人绿，也不是湖人黄。汤姆·奥格雷迪与蒂芙尼蓝的黄蜂队球衣没有任何关系，但他将其视为一个信号，
that the league was ready for bolder designs. It was kind of a leap of faith for the league to say, you know, this is not really something we've seen before, but as an expansion team, we'll probably let you have this one because maybe there's something new we can learn from this. And it turned out fans loved the teal Hornets jersey. It looked fresh and different. It was really very popular. They soon became known as the Men of Teal.
表明联盟已经准备好迎接更大胆的设计。对联盟来说，这有点像是一次信念的飞跃，他们说：“你知道的，这并不是我们以前见过的那种东西，但作为一支扩张球队，我们可能会让你保留这个，因为也许我们可以从中学到一些新东西。”事实证明，球迷们非常喜欢蒂芙尼蓝的黄蜂队球衣。它看起来清新而别具一格。它确实非常受欢迎。他们很快就被称为“蒂芙尼蓝军团”。
And all of a sudden, the Charlotte Hornets had gained great recognition before they'd ever played a basketball game. When Tom O'Grady was hired as the NBA's first creative director two years later in 1990, he wanted to push Jersey design even further, not just the colors, but the designs on the uniforms. Until the early 90s, there had been real limits to how wild you could get with these designs. Because all the details, the numbers, the names and the logos, had to be sewn on. To do any kind of complicated graphics, who would have taken a massive amount of embroidery,
突然之间，夏洛特黄蜂队在他们甚至还没打过一场篮球比赛之前，就已经获得了巨大的知名度。两年后的1990年，当汤姆·奥格雷迪被聘为NBA的第一位创意总监时，他希望将球衣设计推向更远，不仅是颜色，还有球衣上的图案。直到90年代初，这些设计的疯狂程度一直受到真正的限制。因为所有的细节——数字、名字和标志——都必须缝上去。要制作任何复杂的图案，都需要大量的刺绣，
at all that thread would have added additional weight and made the jersey hotter to wear. But soon after Tomo Grady joined the NBA, he would get some new tools to work with. Computer programs like Photoshop and Illustrator helped him dream up new logo designs. And there was a new technique to get those drawings onto a jersey. It was called die sublimation. Sublimation changed everything. Sublimation is a process of printing die
所有的线都会增加额外的重量，并使球衣穿起来更热。但就在汤姆·奥格雷迪加入NBA后不久，他将获得一些用于工作的新工具。像Photoshop和Illustrator这样的计算机程序帮助他构思出新的标志设计。并且有了一种将这些图纸印到球衣上的新技术。它被称为染料升华。升华改变了一切。升华是将染料直接打印到面料中的工艺。
directly into the fabric. Now for the first time, you could design something in Photoshop. You could make it big and you could add up a bunch of different colors. Then with sublimation, you could basically print that design straight onto the material without any embroidery or extra weight. So it allowed us to start to take things we would never normally even consider doing
现在，你第一次可以在Photoshop中进行设计。你可以把它做大，还可以添加一堆不同的颜色。然后通过升华技术，你基本上可以直接将该设计打印到材料上，而无需任何刺绣或额外的重量。因此，这使我们能够开始尝试那些我们通常永远不会考虑在球衣上做的事情，
on a jersey. And we started doing more outrageous uniforms and stuff because we could. We can, so we will. Tom's first big design was for the Phoenix Suns, who were celebrating their 25th year in the league. They were moving into a new arena and they wanted a new look. So Tom met with their team owner, Jerry Calangelo.
我们开始制作更多离谱的队服之类的东西，因为我们能够做到。我们能做到，所以我们就去做。汤姆的第一个重大设计是为菲尼克斯太阳队制作的，当时他们正在庆祝加入联盟25周年。他们即将搬进一个新球馆，并想要一个新的外观。于是汤姆会见了他们的球队老板杰里·卡兰杰洛。
Jerry was great, and he was a fellow Chicagoan, so as soon as you heard my accent, he's like, I think we're gonna get along. I think us Chicago guys kinda get this. Here's what I wanna do. I wanna have a logo that's gonna last for the next 25 years. I don't want to have to change it. So I want something futuristic, but classic. So Tom and his team started on the Suns redesign. They come up with this big basketball. That's also a sun. It has these long red to orange
杰里人很好，而且他是同乡芝加哥人，所以他一听到我的口音，就说：“我觉得我们能合得来。我觉得我们芝加哥人挺懂这个的。这就是我想做的。我想要一个能用未来25年的标志。我不想经常更换它。所以我想要既具有未来感又经典的东西。”于是汤姆和他的团队开始了太阳队的重新设计。他们设计了一个大篮球。它同时也是一个太阳。上面有长长的、从红色渐变到橙色的太阳光芒。
gradient sun rays coming off of it. And then they print this in a bright purple background under their new jersey. It's not exactly what I would call classic, but it is bold. Definitely bold. As luck would have it, the Phoenix Suns made it to the NBA finals that year. And the whole country got to see that bright purple jersey, with its blazing basketball sun, all over national TV. We got exposure for that uniform that was priceless. That changed everything for us. We were able to do things with uniforms that we could not imagine even two years before that.
然后他们将这个图案印在他们新球衣的亮紫色背景上。这不完全是我所说的经典，但它确实很大胆。绝对很大胆。正如运气的安排，菲尼克斯太阳队在那一年打入了NBA总决赛。全国观众都在全国电视上看到了那件带有炽热篮球太阳的亮紫色球衣。我们为那件球衣获得的曝光率是无价的。这彻底改变了我们。我们能够用球衣做出甚至在两年前都无法想象的事情。
Like a teal Detroit Piston's jersey with a flaming horse head logo or a pinstriped Houston rocket jersey featuring a cartoon rocket with an angry face on it. Over the course of the decade, two-thirds of NBA teams got new uniforms, with new logos and new color schemes. There was a lot of teal and purple. 3D lettering and oversized graphics were everywhere. We look back on it and say, wow, this stuff is pretty outlandish, but it's okay because that's what was happening at the time.
比如带有火焰马头标志的青绿色底特律活塞队球衣，或者印有带愤怒表情的卡通火箭的细条纹休斯顿火箭队球衣。在这十年里，三分之二的NBA球队换上了新球衣，带有新的标志和新的配色方案。到处都是青绿色和紫色。3D字体和超大图形随处可见。我们回过头来看，会说：哇，这些东西真是太离谱了，但没关系，因为那是当时正在发生的事情。
The technology led us to go wild. And Tom's boss, NBA Commissioner David Stern, gave him the freedom to keep pushing the designs further. He said, you know, if this is what's selling and if you're telling me, this is what's going to work at retail, um, count me in. Before the 90s, the NBA wasn't doing much with merchandising. If a fan wanted to buy a jersey, they had to pay the full cost of a genuine stitched NBA game jersey, which was sometimes over $200. But with all these popular new designs, Tom and others at the NBA got thinking. Why don't we have a jersey that we can sell for about $45 to $50 that looks similar to the game jersey.
技术推动我们走向疯狂。汤姆的老板、NBA总裁大卫·斯特恩给了他自由，让他继续推动设计的边界。他说：“你知道的，如果这就是畅销的，如果你告诉我说，这就是在零售端能行得通的，嗯，算我一个。”在90年代之前，NBA在商业开发上并没有做太多事情。如果球迷想买一件球衣，他们必须支付一件真正的、带有刺绣的NBA比赛球衣的全价，有时超过200美元。但随着所有这些广受欢迎的新设计，汤姆和NBA的其他人员开始思考。为什么我们不推出一款售价约为45到50美元、看起来与比赛球衣相似的球衣呢？
And we saw this business explode, you know, in five years. It went from almost like a baseline of nothing to a multi-million dollar business, largely in the jerseys that we were designing. The era about landage NBA uniforms reached its apex in 1995. With that jersey we talked about at the beginning, that one from Toronto.
我们看到这项业务在五年内爆发式增长。它几乎从零基线发展成为一个价值数百万美元的业务，这在很大程度上要归功于我们设计的球衣。90年代荒诞NBA球衣的时代在1995年达到了顶峰。就是我们一开始谈到的那件球衣，来自多伦多那件。
The one that some people call the Barney design. We were told directly by the team owner at the time, John Bitov, it would like the happy meal box of uniform designs. And we kind of looked at him, and it was like, what did he mean by that? He said, I'm not gonna wear this uniform forever. Kids don't eat out of a happy meal box forever,
也就是被有些人称为“巴尼”设计的那件。当时的球队老板约翰·比托夫直接告诉我们，它看起来就像球衣设计界的“开心乐园餐”盒子。我们看了看他，心里想：他这话是什么意思？他说：“我不会永远穿着这件球衣。小孩子们也不会永远吃开心乐园餐的盒子，
but if you can get the kids into your store, you're going to win them over. If happy meal design isn't a term yet, I'm making it one right now. The goal was to convince hockey loving kids in Toronto that they should care about this new basketball team. And so we created this purple uniform with these jagged edge club pen stripes that looked like a raptured common ripped it. And then they that look like a raptor come and ripped it. And then they slapped a big dinosaur right in the middle of it. And they made it red because Canada. He wanted red-raptive to represent Canada, which made all the sense in the world. I don't know how much sense that made, but that jersey it sold.
但如果你能把孩子们吸引到你的商店里，你就赢得了他们。”如果“开心乐园餐设计”这个词还不存在，我现在就创造一个。当时的目标是让多伦多热爱冰球的孩子们觉得他们应该关心这支崭新的篮球队。于是我们创造了这件紫色球衣，上面带有锯齿状边缘的俱乐部细条纹，看起来就像是被猛龙撕裂过一样。然后它们看起来就像是一只猛龙过来撕裂了它。接着他们在正中间印上了一只巨大的恐龙。而且他们把它做成了红色，因为这里是加拿大。他希望红色的猛龙能代表加拿大，这在当时极其合理。我不知道这有多大合理性，但那件球衣确实卖爆了。
I think it was the top-selling expansion team logo we ever did even today. It sales were through the roof. Before they ever played a game, before the team had even signed a single player, the Raptors were seventh in the league in merchandise sales. But as the 90s came to an end, change was a foot, and stuff was about to get a lot more boring. By the early 2000s, the NBA had become a booming global industry, and wealthy business people were suddenly interested in team ownership.
我想这是我们做过的最畅销的扩张球队标志，即使在今天也是如此。它的销量简直直冲云霄。在他们甚至还没打过一场比赛、球队甚至还没签下哪怕一名球员之前，猛龙队的商品销售额就排在联盟第七位。但随着90年代接近尾声，变革即将来临，一切也将变得枯燥得多。到了2000年代初，NBA已成为一个蓬勃发展的全球产业，富商们突然对球队所有权产生了兴趣。
People like Howard Schultz, who turned Starbucks into a multi-billion-dollar business. In 2001, Schultz bought the Seattle Super Sonics, and he came into the league with a whole laundry list of changes to make. He wanted to replace the hip-hop you'd hear in the arena on Game Night with Jazz. He wanted his team to stick to the fundamentals, less flashy dunks and show-boding. He favored team basketball over individual stars, which was actually really bad for his team because it pissed off their actual stars. Also Schult hated the Sonic's 90s look that had been designed by another than our pal Tom.
比如霍华德·舒尔茨，他把星巴克变成了一家价值数十亿美元的企业。2001年，舒尔茨买下了西雅图超音速队，他带着一长串的改革清单进入了联盟。他想把比赛之夜在球馆里听到的嘻哈音乐换成爵士乐。他希望他的球队坚守基本功，减少花哨的扣篮和炫耀。他更喜欢团队篮球而不是个人球星，这实际上对他的球队非常糟糕，因为它惹恼了他们的真正的球星。此外，舒尔茨讨厌超音速队90年代的造型，那个造型正是由我们的老朋友汤姆设计的。
We were able to take this kind of basketball spinning around the space needle and kind of have this super man font and added toward Sonic's in there. And they changed the colors from green and gold to dark green, red and a metallic bronze. Old Howard Jazz instead of hip-hop shults was not a fan, so he hired Seattle design firm Hornel Anderson to completely remake the Sonic's graphic identity. That's Jersey's warm-ups, logos, everything. I get my pants, I was so damn excited. This is Andrew Wickland, who is the lead designer on the project. I hated what the Sonic's looked like at that time too, and a lot of other teams, frankly, that had been rebranded in the 90s, so yeah, it was like a candy store.
我们能够将这种在太空针塔周围旋转的篮球融入其中，并采用这种超人字体，然后在里面添加了“Sonics”字样。他们把颜色从绿色和金色改为深绿色、红色和金属青铜色。古板的霍华德喜欢爵士乐而不是嘻哈乐，舒尔茨不是这个风格的粉丝，所以他聘请了西雅图设计公司霍内尔·安德森来彻底重塑超音速队的视觉形象。也就是球衣、热身服、标志，一切。我惊掉下巴，我太兴奋了。这是安德·威克兰，该项目的首席设计师。我也讨厌超音速队当时的造型，老实说，还有很多其他在90年代重新做过品牌重塑的球队，所以，是的，这感觉就像进了一家糖果店。
The direction they were given was clear. Immediately go back to the old classic green and gold color scheme, and do something iconic. Howard's words were, I want this to be something that nobody would ever want to change. I want it to be the Chicago Cubs, the New York Yankees, the Green Bay Packers. Those are solid shapes, simple shapes. They are simple color palettes. It's simplification. Is it strength? By the start of the 2001-2002 season, everything was in place. Green and gold, no 3D anything, no giant loggers across the chest. The uniforms looked like an update, or the ones they'd started wearing in the late 70s.
给他们的方向很明确。立刻回归古朴经典的绿金配色，做一些标志性的东西。霍华德的原话是：“我希望这个东西是永远没人想去改变的。我希望它是芝加哥小熊队、纽约扬基队、绿湾包装工队。”那些是坚实的形状，简单的形状。它们是简单的调色板。这就是简化。这就是力量？到2001-2002赛季开始时，一切都已到位。绿色和金色，没有3D效果，胸前也没有巨大的标志。这些球衣看起来像是对他们70年代末开始穿的球衣的更新版。
But if Howard Schultz was committed to making the Sonics an iconic franchise with an iconic look, his commitment didn't last very long. In 2006, he sold the team, and the new owners moved the Sonics to Oklahoma City. But Schultz's aesthetic vision rippled throughout the league. Throughout the odds, one team after another slowly returned to the old color schemes, and lost their big graphic jerseys. Even though Raptors' look has completely changed, this year the two main jerseys were red
但如果说霍华德·舒尔茨致力于让超音速队成为一个拥有标志性外观的标志性特许球队，他的承诺并没有持续太久。2006年，他卖掉了球队，新老板将超音速队搬到了俄克拉荷马城。但舒尔茨的美学愿景在整个联盟中激起了涟漪。整个2000年代，各支球队一个接一个地慢慢恢复了旧的配色方案，并抛弃了他们那些巨大的图形球衣。尽管猛龙队的外观已经彻底改变，但今年他们的两件主要球衣是红色的
and white, and they just say Raptors on the front in a This year the two main jerseys were red and white and they just say Raptors on the front in a simple font. No crazy claw marks, no dinosaurs. And it's like I've seen better inner-me-er old jerseys at college. Here is Tom O'Grady again. There's just nothing to them. There's zero, they're lifeless and I don't get it. Say what you will about Tom O'Grady's jerseys, but they were not lifeless. His designs are mostly gone from the NBA now, but they live on in blog posts and listicles of people's favorite jerseys from NBA history, or their least favorite. In their 2015 list of the ugliest basketball jerseys of all time, sports illustrated wrote, quote, Quote, the Toronto Raptors cartoon dinosaur logo is one of the worst in all of sports.
和白色的，它们在正面用简单的字体写着“Raptors”。没有疯狂的爪痕，没有恐龙。感觉就像我在大学里见过更好的复古球衣。汤姆·奥格雷迪再次登场。它们毫无特色。它们是零，它们毫无生气，我不明白。不管你怎么评价汤姆·奥格雷迪的球衣，它们绝对不是毫无生气的。他的设计现在大部分已经从NBA消失了，但它们活在博客文章和人们对NBA历史最喜爱（或最讨厌）球衣的盘点中。在其2015年评选的史上最丑篮球球衣榜单中，《体育画报》写道，引用：多伦多猛龙队的卡通恐龙标志是体育界最糟糕的标志之一。
Thankfully, it will soon be extinct. But Tom doesn't mind when people call his designs garish, or even ugly. He's proud of our Raptors jersey. It was meant to be provocative, it was meant to be kind of eye-catching. We could have taken and started out with, you know, a 72-point helvetica that says Toronto in a big number on the back-and-call of the day, but I think that would not have been a memorable identity or nor a great way to introduce a new team into a new market.
谢天谢地，它很快就会灭绝。但当人们称他的设计花哨甚至丑陋时，汤姆并不介意。他为我们的猛龙球衣感到自豪。它本来就是要具有挑衅性的，本来就是要引人注目的。我们可以拿出一款72磅黑体、背面写着“多伦多”和一个大数字的球衣来应付了事，但我觉得那不会是一个令人难忘的身份标识，也不是将一支新球队引入一个新市场的好方法。
And if people are still talking about it, then he did his job, right? I'm fine with the criticism about people thinking it's the worst thing ever because it certainly says that we noticed it, we have an opinion about it, we have a strong opinion about it, but we remember it and I think that's great. And the Raptor's original plan to hook kids with the happy meal of NBA jerseys. Love it or hate it, you could argue that it worked. Today Toronto has a loyal fan base, and over the past five years they've had some of the highest attendance numbers in the league.
如果人们还在谈论它，那么他就完成任务了，对吧？我不在乎别人批评它是最糟糕的东西，因为这肯定说明我们注意到了它，我们对它有看法，我们对它有强烈的看法，但我们记住了它，我觉得这很棒。至于猛龙队用NBA球衣里的“开心乐园餐”吸引孩子们的最初计划。不管你爱它还是恨它，可以说它成功了。今天，多伦多拥有了一支忠实的球迷基础，在过去五年里，他们的上座率一直名列联盟前茅。
And as for those bold 90s jerseys, they haven't actually gone extinct. There are now entire companies that produce retro jerseys and many of the designs Tom O'Grady and his team came up with are really popular. And one of the top sellers is a bright purple jersey with a jagged claw-cut pinstripes and a red dinosaur, ribbling a basketball.
至于那些90年代的大胆球衣，它们实际上并没有灭绝。现在有整家整家的公司在生产复古球衣，汤姆·奥格雷迪和他的团队想出的许多设计都非常受欢迎。其中最畅销的一款就是亮紫色球衣，带有锯齿状的爪痕细条纹和一只正在运球的红色恐龙。
Because Oakland's warriors swept the finals, this episode about basketball jerseys missed the season by just a hair, but I have good news for you. It's time for the World Cup, and we have the perfect design nerd World Cup conversation starter after this. So most major sports that involve a ball, including basketball and baseball and American football, they went through early periods in which actual ball designs varied a whole lot. But in general, the shapes and the materials and dimensions and the basic look have all become standardized over time.
由于奥克兰勇士队在总决赛中横扫对手，这期关于篮球球衣的节目与本赛季擦肩而过，但我有个好消息告诉你。世界杯时间到了，在接下来的节目中，我们将为您带来完美的、适合设计爱好者的世界杯谈资。所以，大多数涉及球权的重大运动，包括篮球、棒球和美式足球，都经历过早期阶段，当时实际的球类设计有很大的差异。但总的来说，随着时间的推移，形状、材料、尺寸和基本外观都已经标准化了。
You know, in the NBA, you've got a big brown ball of a certain exact size with thin black lines. Major League Baseball, there's a small white sphere made with exactly 180 double stitches of red. Exactly. And then in the NFL, everybody uses the same brown pro late spheroid with white stripes and laces along the top, inflated to a very narrow pressure range of around 13 PSI. Or you get in trouble.
你知道，在NBA，你有一个特定确切大小的、带有细黑线的棕色大球。美国职业棒球大联盟，有一个由刚好180道红色双针缝线制成的小白球。分毫不差。然后是在NFL，每个人都使用相同的棕色职业长椭球体，顶部有白色的条纹和鞋带，充气到一个非常狭窄的压力范围内，大约13 PSI。否则你就会惹上麻烦。
Yeah, big trouble. Oh, yeah, these are carefully inspected, measured, stamped, and sequestered before the game. That is Kurt Colestad. I'm talking to his digital director. And we're going to talk about a type of ball that is a bit less consistent. It continues to change year after year. It is the soccer ball.
是的，大麻烦。哦，是的，这些球在比赛前都要经过仔细检查、测量、盖章和隔离。那是库尔特·科尔斯特。我正在和他的数字总监交谈。我们要讨论一种一致性稍差的球。它年复一年地不断变化。这就是足球。
In 1930, at the first World Cup, the two teams competing in the final game couldn't agree on what ball to use. So FIFA actually stepped in and had them alternate between two different balls, using one team's pick for the first half and the other team's pick for the second half of the game. Going forward, FIFA ruled that there would be just one ball per competition. That makes sense. So the two balls in 1930 looked pretty similar. They looked kind of like volleyball, so it was pretty rough looking,
1930年，在第一届世界杯上，参加决赛的两支球队无法就使用哪种球达成一致。因此国际足联实际上介入并让他们在两个不同的球之间交替使用，上半场使用一支球队挑选的球，下半场使用另一支球队挑选的球。从那以后，国际足联规定每场比赛只能使用一个球。这很合理。所以1930年的那两个球看起来挺相似的。它们看起来有点像排球，所以看起来挺粗糙的，
and you could see the laces around it, too. Yeah, and those were pretty typical for the time, and for the decades after, most balls of that period followed the same basic model. Long strips of leather stitched together into a rough sphere, most were of a single solid color, too, usually neutral browns, yellows, oranges, off whites. But the ball design I grew up with didn't look like that at all.
而且你也能看到它周围的鞋带。是的，这在当时很典型，在随后的几十年里，那个时期的绝大多数球都遵循相同的基本模型。长条皮革缝合成一个粗糙的球体，大多数也是单一的纯色，通常是中性的棕色、黄色、橙色、米白色。但我成长过程中见过的球设计可完全不是那样。
It was made up of this very uniform patchwork of high contrast, black and white geometric shapes. And that's the same exact ball I grew up with. That classic soccer ball that's very recognizable and basically iconic at this point. In fact, if you do an image search on the web for soccer ball icon, that's exactly what you'll find. And so how did this become the design that everyone thinks of?
它由这种非常统一的高对比度黑白几何图形拼凑而成。这正是我小时候用的同款球。那个经典的足球非常容易辨认，在这一点上基本上已经成为了标志性符号。事实上，如果你在网页上进行图片搜索“足球图标”，你就会找到这个。那么，这怎么就成了每个人心中的设计呢？
Well, soccer balls first started featuring this distinctive pattern of, you know, pentagons and hexagons in the 1960s. But then it got really famous when FIFA used a version made by Adidas for the 1970 World Cup. They wanted something high contrast, so the gameplay would be easier for viewers at home to follow on black and white television screens The so-called tell star ball was an instant hit. The name tell star is a portmanteau of the words television and star Because it was meant to be the perfect soccer ball for televised games The name was borrowed from the tell star communication satellite
嗯，足球是在20世纪60年代首次开始采用这种独特的五边形和六边形图案的。但后来它变得非常有名，是在国际足联在1970年世界杯上使用了阿迪达斯制造的一个版本之后。他们想要高对比度的东西，这样黑白电视屏幕前的观众就能更容易地跟着比赛进程走。所谓的“电视之星”球一炮而红。“Telstar”这个名字是“television”（电视）和“star”（星星）两个词的混成词。因为它的目标是成为适合转播比赛的完美足球。这个名字借用了通信卫星“电视之星”的名字，
Which was white and spherical and had black solar panels all around it a lot of subsequent balls have continued to use the same basic approach of alternating darks and lights, but the designs have really evolved, too. Over the years, official balls went from having 32 to 14 to just eight panels or fewer in some cases. And this isn't just cosmetic. Those different number of panels actually change the function of the ball. Yeah, they affect the shape and how the ball performs on the field. They make a really big sort of structural difference. So can you tell me about this year's ball? Yeah, so this year Adidas, who, you know, they've been designing these balls since 1970,
它是白色的，呈球形，四周都是黑色的太阳能电池板。后来的很多球都继续采用了明暗交替的这种基本方法，但设计也确实在不断演变。多年来，官方比赛球的块数从32块、14块减少到某些情况下的8块甚至更少。这不仅仅是为了外观。那些不同数量的块实际上改变了球的功能。是的，它们影响了形状以及球在球场上的表现。它们产生了非常大的结构上的差异。那么你能告诉我今年这款球的情况吗？好的，今年阿迪达斯——你知道的，他们从1970年起就开始设计这些球了，
and that famous Telstar ball, they're back again, and this time they're actually bringing back the Telstar with the Telstar 18. How similar is the Telstar 18 to the original Telstar from 1970? So it does have black and white, but this new six panel design actually also features a digital grid pattern of gray pixels that fade between the extremes. And while the original Telstar could be easily abstracted into a logo or shrunk down into an emoji, this one has too much detail for that. It seems more designed to sell the latest cool looking ball than to actually work as an icon. Right, I guess you can't make icons every single year.
还有那个著名的“电视之星”球——他们又回来了，这一次他们实际上是通过“电视之星18”（Telstar 18）将“电视之星”带了回来。“电视之星18”和1970年的原版“电视之星”有多相似？它确实有黑白两色，但这个新的六块拼接设计实际上还具有灰色像素的数字网格图案，在极端之间逐渐淡化。虽然原版的“电视之星”可以很容易地抽象成一个标志或缩小成一个表情符号，但这款球的细节太多了。它看起来更像是为了销售最新酷炫外观的球，而不是真正作为一个图标起作用。对吧，我想你不可能每年都创造出图标。
Yeah, not every year. But it's crazy to me that they keep painting the design and forcing professional players to deal with different shapes and weights and aerodynamics over and over a year after year. That's crazy to me. Yeah, it's been a big source of controversy too. Ahead of these World Cup competitions, some players complain about having to figure out how the latest new ball will actually behave on the field.
对，不是每年都能。但对我来说疯狂的是，他们不断改变设计，强迫职业球员年复一年地去应对不同的形状、重量和空气动力学。这对我来说太疯狂了。是的，这也一直是争议的主要来源。在这些世界杯比赛之前，一些球员抱怨不得不去琢磨最新的新球在球场上到底会有什么表现。
And it kind of makes you wonder if FIFA should just stick to one basic uniform structural design. Right. Like, figure out what the best geometry and materials, and then you can make superficial changes that change the look, but don't change the actual function of the ball. But meanwhile, for better or worse, there are a lot of different designs out there, and you can see a ton of them on our website. It's at 99pi.org. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Whitney Jones and Emmett Fitzgerald. Whitney is the host of the show Pitch, whose next season is coming out on Audible at the
这让人不禁怀疑，国际足联是否应该坚持一种基本的统一结构设计。对吧。比如，弄清楚什么是最佳的几何形状和材料，然后你可以做一些改变外观的表层改动，但不要改变球的实际功能。但与此同时，不管好坏，外面有很多不同的设计，你可以在我们的网站上看到一大堆。网址是 99pi.org。“99%隐形”本周由惠特尼·琼斯和埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作。惠特尼是节目《Pitch》的主持人，该节目的下一季将于本月底6月29日在Audible上架。我们的混音和技术制作由谢里·富塞夫完成，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。高级制作人凯蒂·曼格尔和乔·罗斯伯格负责剪辑。团队的其他成员包括数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特、高级编辑塔拉尼·霍尔、埃弗里·特劳夫曼、维维安·李、泰伦·马泽特以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，在无线电街区制作。
end of this month on June 29th. Our Mix and Tech production was by Sheree Fusef, Music by Sean Rial. Senior producer Katie Mangle and Joe Rosenberg handled the editing. The rest of the team is Digital Director Kurt Colstead, Senior Editor to Lany Hall, Avery Trouffman, Vivian Lee, Taren Mazet, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. In beautiful, downtown, confetti-streamreen Oakland, California. 99% Infosible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows and all of podcasting.
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽、繁华市中心、飘满彩带的街道上。“99%隐形”是PRX旗下RadioTopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚定的独立集体。
Fun more at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But I have a few follow-up episodes for you. If you want to really geek out about sports uniforms, find episode 111 featuring Paul Lucas of UniWatch and Jesse Thorn of NPR's Bullseye talking about baseball, Hozary. Seriously, it's great.
访问 radiotopia.fm 了解更多信息。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（@Roman Mars）以及节目（@99PI org）。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但我为你准备了几期后续节目。如果你想真正对运动球衣着迷，请收听第111集，其中采访了来自UniWatch的保罗·卢卡斯和NPR《Bullseye》的杰西·索恩，他们谈论了棒球球衣。说真的，太棒了。
And if you want more from Whitney Jones and Pitch, check out the episode we did with them on Ariam's Out of Time and how it may be the most important political album of all time because of its packaging. That's episode number one 24. You can find them both on Apple podcasts or by searching our beautiful and functional website. It's 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想要更多来自惠特尼·琼斯和《Pitch》的内容，请查看我们与他们合作制作的关于阿里姆的《Out of Time》的那集，以及它如何因其包装而成为史上最重要的政治专辑之一。那是第124集。你可以在苹果播客上找到这两集，或者通过搜索我们美丽实用的网站来找到。网址是 99pi.org。本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。